[Music]
you know what I got back into this
weekend bro what Starcraft oh really
yeah damn like why
um that's a great question
it's basically it's
basically it's chess okay it's like all
about strategy and it's what well I'm
nice to try beautiful
these you think these plebeian listeners
are even ready to discuss StarCraft one
I'm playing Starcraft 2 okay
yeah
um I got a funny ass gaming story
actually I can't wait to hear this no I
so I started playing Starcraft 2 again
and it's fun you know when I used to
play I was like definitely you know I
was ego playing a lot so I got really
[ __ ] ass hurt when I lost and it was
such like a emotional thing now I'm the
old guy playing typically people for
manners they'll go good luck have fun we
all do this and at the end of the game
I'll [ __ ] you know hey good game man
ggs ggs and some of these guys that when
I say GG they take it as opportunity to
be shitty so I start being a [ __ ] dad
about it I'm like whoa
why so aggro and they go no no I was
just
I was kidding and then it made me think
how many of these guys these young men
are playing every day
and not they win and not a single person
in their life acknowledges what they're
doing on the ladder okay like they're
grinding every day right I I I beat some
guy and then I looked at the ladder and
I was looking at his record and I was
like noticing and I'm like holy [ __ ]
this one kid right here he's not good at
this game and he has 110 games this
season already and he cannot net
positive
a win ratio right he's only just one
ahead he's 54 and 53 I'm like God he
sucks right he's really trying yeah so
now my new thing is uh
at the end of games I compliment these
guys
uh some guy being last night I was like
hey good game man I'm like that build is
fast the your good technique yeah yeah
no not even I'm I'm legitimate I like I
had some guy last night I was like oh
man I'm like this build's super
interesting you do this often he's like
no just in this matchup he's like thanks
man yeah yeah and he he has no I I don't
usually do okay log off yeah
sorry man didn't need your life story
piece nah it's just like some corny
positivity [ __ ] I love that yeah and
then I just spread positivity yeah you
know it's important and then it was
funny because he started complimenting
me back
you started flirting back
I was like how is like it's a fast bill
I had no idea I had the info I didn't
know where to take it he's like no you
scouted it like super well like the way
you used the centuries like was really
good like so good all you had to do was
this and like you totally would have won
so and I but here's the best part I told
some guy another guy I was like ah man
I'm like I'm like great job I'm like
okay just reinstalled I'm getting my ass
kicked he's like oh me too man I've been
getting my ass beat I was like well you
won tonight brother I left so this
before I was playing the ranked games I
didn't realize I had to like basically
pay
to play ranked again it's like a little
nice little scam that they run so I was
playing an unranked which is like that's
just people being shitty right so I just
sort of
not thinking like oh good gay man
um I'm like I just reinstalled is this
like did you do this XYZ
and he goes I just reinstalled two this
is my first game ever I'm six
laughs
so I did a video like a couple months
ago about the metaverse where I went
into Horizon worlds and [ __ ] around
and so I did another one of those
probably gonna post it tomorrow I think
so this is like not
it'll already be out so I can whatever
so
one of the funny parts is like I go into
this world and I'm playing this like I
usually like to film in the morning but
like no one's on VR in the morning no
bro right it's like which almost makes
it funnier because every interaction is
just like these solo people just sitting
in empty rooms it's so [ __ ] weird and
you're like what are you doing and
they're like ah
and you're like I don't understand are
you just sitting in your living room
with the goggles on not expecting to see
people like what what are you what is
your life 10 30 in the morning
this guy goes this guy goes uh what's up
man and I'm like what are you doing he's
like oh man I'm just getting ready
I'm like what do you mean you're getting
ready he's like I'm in Vegas
I'm like so you're getting ready in
Vegas with the Oculus on
and he was like ah man it's good to meet
you and he plays a song and it starts
going oh he like he's he's like turning
up
oh but I don't understand like how it
works with the headset on like
it's nice [ __ ] bizarre so it popped
into this one room
and I'm like hey what's up and they're
like hi and I'm like ah [ __ ] children
kid and I'm like start to go and he's
like I'm a hacker
and I was like what he's like yeah I'm a
hacker I'm eight
I was like what kind of hacks can you do
he's like I don't know YouTube has
taught me some hacks
and I was like okay man and like as I'm
like pushing the menu to get out of the
thing I'm like
by the way do you ever like go outside
and like ride bikes and he goes
yesterday I throw it up
like legitimately it's not someone
[ __ ] with me there's a real
eight-year-old child he goes yesterday I
throwed up it was all green with like
white little stuff inside of it I was
like what am I doing I'm [ __ ] yeah
yeah
I was like what the [ __ ] is going on
like who allows their children to be in
the metaverse like that did he throw up
from the VR I don't know he wasn't I
didn't like try to like get more info I
was just like I no no I'm brainstorming
like I feel like is he in VR and he
tried to ride a bicycle and then the
actual people made him sick yeah Mommy
the real world made me sick I was like
if you don't even know the proper tense
of
through you're not at that point in life
yet like you should not be on like on
Oculus and the metaverse I flew up
I throwed up
so then so then I get so then I get uh
like Sam has been asking us forever yeah
to all get in the metaverse again yeah
so finally for some reason it was Sunday
everyone was like let's do it let's log
on 3 45 we're getting on so we're all
like okay so we we collect you know we
we group up in this one house Sam's
house or whatever and we're all like
looking each other's avatars laughing
and I'm laughing at Adam and Devin
because both their usernames are their
real names
and it's like guys it's the metaverse
you can be whatever you want yeah you
know like you don't have to use your
real names and they're like oh we can't
change it so whatever and so okay
whatever
so we pop in a couple rooms right it's
like more lively at 3 45 like people are
especially on a Sunday like people are
actually there
and then we go to this room it's
completely empty and it's like a
hospital and so they start [ __ ] with
me and they're like you know we're just
messing around like yo put on your mask
please blah blah blah yeah and then Sam
goes uh Cody I have your test results
here
and I'm like oh really he's like yeah
walk around the corner I've written your
diagnosis on the Whiteboard and I'm like
okay and I walk around the corner and it
says like small penis itis or something
like that and we're laughing about that
just like [ __ ] being [ __ ] right
all of a sudden this random it's only Us
in this room this random guy pops in
and he we kind of hear him over to the
side and then he comes over he goes Adam
and Adam goes
what and he goes it's Brad from Dropbox
Adam at work for Dropbox like five years
ago this guy is co-worker at Dropbox
from five or six years ago popped into
this room recognized his username
and they launched into like the same
[ __ ] small talk that you have when
you see someone you haven't seen in a
long time
and we're over here laughing at small
penis itis and in the background we hear
like so have you been pretty good man
I'm working for Google Now
it was the most bizarre random
depressing thing ever it's so funny to
log into the metaphor I know I'd be like
this world of possibilities and you end
up doing this small talk yeah running
into a stranger like running into
someone you haven't seen in seven years
at a coffee shop
it was [ __ ] crazy